on a joué on a rigolé ensemble
et vous désirez vraiment fort
mais on n'avait pas la capacité
on est au Colorado avec deux clubs la
spontania et le club de la redonnaise
Redoute et on passe une petite journée
conviviale ensemble il y a quelques
semaines on est parti à Metz avec nos
jeunes de l'AS redoute on a on est parti
on a participé à un tournoi
international que peut organiser messe
le Conseil général nous a aidé
financièrement
ce sont les bénévoles et il faut leur
rendre hommage qui
accompagne
tous ces sportifs en herbe parce que le
sport c'est aussi l'école de la vie
motivés et ils veulent déjà s'entraîner
pour l'année prochaine c'est bénéfique
aussi dans notre formation donc nous on
prend des renseignements de masse pour
amener ici à La Redoute pour faire
profiter aux jeunes et c'est bénéfique
aussi pour le club et la Réunion
les valeurs qui sont prônées par le
sport la culture la rencontre vers
l'autre de l'autre et bien ça ça crée un
homme ça fait son homme ça n'est pas
seulement faire des Champions mais à la
réunion nous en faisons mais les
sportifs en herbe ce sont des grands
réunionnais et être champion de
l'identité créole ça aussi